[Musik]
herzlich willkommen bei zdf heute live
zum zweiten mal heute an diesem tag denn
es gibt neuigkeiten
soeben ist eine rede von präsident putin
im russischen staatsfernsehen zu ende
gegangen und dort hat der präsident
verkündet russland will die ukrainischen
regionen lohans und dann jetzt in der
ukraine als unabhängig anerkennen das
wird folgen haben nicht nur für gerade
den andauernden konflikt sondern
vermutlich auch für uns alle in europa
wir können darüber sprechen mit unserem
russland korrespondent gerade in der
ukraine in kiew erreichen wir axel sturm
der das ganze für uns einordnen kann
schönen guten abend achse
ich müsste ihn jetzt sehen und er ist
mir hoffentlich gleich auch zugeschaltet
manchmal dauert das ein bisschen und
jetzt ist er da hallo axel schirm guten
abend
schönen guten abend axel wir haben das
soeben gehört und wir haben uns auch
diese einstündige rede eine stunde gegen
diese rede von präsident putin im
staatsfernsehen angeschaut wir beide und
ganz am ende dann also die verkündung
lohans kontern jens und jetzt die beiden
unabhängigen
volksrepublik 'nen sollen sollen
anerkannt werden ich habe kann ich ihren
störgeräusch auf dem ort deswegen jetzt
noch einmal die frage an dich axel was
wird das für folgen haben diese ansage
eben gerade von präsident putin
das wird natürlich ganz immense folgen
haben aber nicht notwendigerweise
dramatische folgen ich komme dazu später
noch mal lassen sie mich erst kurz sagen
dass das tatsächlich ein wie ich glaube
historischer moment war eine historische
rede wir haben einen russischen
staatspräsidenten erlebt der unheimlich
gefasst sehr konzentriert und sehr
detailreich geschildert hat warum es aus
seiner sicht notwendig ist für die
sicherheit der russischen föderation
diesen administrativen schritt zu gehen
dieser schritt ist ein schritt der auf
unterschiedlichen ebenen sehr komplex
ist es ist ein völkerrechtlicher schritt
aus den augen der russischen föderation
der natürlich international auf keinen
anklang stoßen wird es ist ein
strategischer schritt und es wird
sicherlich auch ein
entwicklungspolitischer schritt sein am
ende des tages aber hat wladimir putin
heute eine rede gehalten über
machtpolitik in der quintessenz ist
dieser schritt macht politik machterhalt
stärke zeigen gegenüber dem westen auch
mal für ihre frage zurückzukommen was
bedeutet das das bedeutet dass die
russische föderation die russische
staatsregierung vertreten durch den
russischen präsidenten die beiden
sogenannten volksrepublik bonn jetzt und
lohans als souveräne staaten anerkennt
und demzufolge könnte es sein dass diese
beiden aus russischer sicht souveränen
staaten um militärische unterstützung
von russland bitten und die kann dann
natürlich auch gewährleistet werden das
wäre sozusagen ein sehr negatives
szenario ein dramatisches szenario von
dem ich aber im jetzigen moment auch
noch nicht ausgehen würde es kann sein
dass das was wir heute abend von
wladimir putin gehört haben eines seiner
spielfiguren auf diesem großen
geopolitischen schachbrett ist dass er
weiter den druck aufbauen will
militärisch hatte ihn schon aufgebaut
aber jetzt auch mit diesem schritt dem
westen noch zu zeigen seht her wir
machen das weil wir es können
wir haben diesen kurzen ausschnitt jetzt
am ende als er das eben angekündigt hat
seiner rede auch vorliegen wir schauen
kurz zusammen rein
und jetzt höre ich gerade wir haben ihn
nicht vorliegen aber das ist nicht
schlimm das ging jetzt heute eben gerade
alles bisschen schnell wir wussten auch
nicht genau wann also das gespräch zu
ende gehen wird von oder die ihre
ansprache zu ende gehen wird von
vladimir putin ich schaue gerade mal ob
ich hier vorliegen habe und zwar am ende
sagte er russland werde die
unabhängigkeit der separatisten gebiete
anerkennen man werde jetzt verträge für
freundschaft und gegenseitige
unterstützung
vorbereiten so hieß es axel was meint
dass genau verträge für freundschaft das
können wir uns darunter vorstellen
verträge für freundschaft dass es einen
begriff noch aus alten sowjet-zeiten die
freundschaft zwischen ländern wurde zu
zeiten der sowjetunion immer groß
gepflegt groß gefeiert es wurden große
denkmäler gebaut in vielen
sowjetrepubliken wenn sie heute an die
grenze zwischen belarus der ukraine und
russland fahren steht dort ein
gigantisches denkmal das an die
freundschaft der drei länder erinnern
soll also das ist sozusagen gute alte
politische kultur aber diese verträge
die da jetzt ausgearbeitet werden sollen
die werden natürlich mit leben und mit
inhalt gefüllt
das kann wie ich eben schon geschildert
habe reichen von militärischer
unterstützung möglicherweise verlagerung
von soldaten in diese in diese dann
anerkannten von russland anerkannten
volksrepublik das kann aber auch
entwicklungspolitische zusammenarbeit
sein das können hilfsgütertransporte
sein das können wirtschaftsmaßnahmen
sein all das ist möglich es war wie
schon angesprochen eine wahnsinnig lange
rede eine stunde lang es waren auch
viele vorwürfe dabei unter anderem hat
putin der ukraine das
selbstbestimmungsrecht vielmehr
abgesprochen er hat gesagt eine eigene
starts tradition hätte das land nicht es
sei dem land nie gelungen einen stabilen
staat zu schaffen so putin und er hat
der ukraine auch vorgeworfen atomwaffen
bauen zu wollen warum hat er so weit
ausgeholt also dieser ganze aufbau und
diese ganzen anschuldigungen gegenüber
über ukraine was will er damit jetzt
vielleicht zusätzlich noch bezwecken
er hat heute abend sehr weit ausgeholt
aber man muss in erinnerung haben dass
er schon sehr viel früher noch viel
weiter ausgeholt hat er hatte im
vergangenen sommer zum beispiel ein
essay geschrieben das auch
veröffentlicht wurde auf den regierungs
webseiten ein durchaus beachtetes es
aber ein es dass in den massenmedien
nicht sonderlich also im westen in den
massenmedien im westen keine sonderlich
hohe breitenwirkung entfaltet hat aber
in diesem essay hatte er sich damals
schon
auseinandergesetzt mit der langen
geschichte der ukraine und der
russischen föderation und der frage ob
die ukraine und die russische föderation
völkerrechtlich überhaupt getrennte
völker sein können das ist nämlich
eigentlich das zumindest ist meine
einschätzung etwas was ihn sehr sehr
stört es gibt durchaus in russland eine
große gruppe von menschen die gar nicht
verstehen können dass es in kiew eine
souveräne selbstständige unabhängige
regierung gibt wo man doch über so viele
jahrzehnte zusammen gehört hat und wo
man doch über so viele jahrhunderte
eigentlich aus dem kiewer rus entstammt
sozusagen der keimzelle der frühen
russischen nation das sind sehr
intellektuelle debatten die da geführt
werden und ich glaube ich wage mich mal
aus dem fenster zu lehnen und zu
behaupten dass präsident putin diesen
untergang der sowjetunion serbe trauert
auch heute noch aus den
unterschiedlichsten politischen gründen
und deswegen war es ihm wahrscheinlich
heute auch so wichtig so detailliert auf
das verhältnis zwischen der ukraine und
russland einzugehen haben natürlich auch
viele fragen bei uns aus der community
zum beispiel von max haase der sich
fragt passiert jetzt dasselbe wie auf
der grimm hoch fragliches referendum und
dann einverleibung in die russische
föderation
die frage kann man mit seriosität nicht
beantworten das steht in den sternen wir
unterhalten uns ja in diesen wochen fast
jeden tag darüber über diese prominente
frage was will putin das ist ja
inzwischen fast schon ein geflügeltes
wort geworden in der berichterstattung
nicht nur bei uns sondern bei vielen
internationalen fernsehsendern niemand
kann in den kopf des russischen
staatspräsidenten gucken aber natürlich
gibt es szenarien es gibt ja auch schon
sozusagen szenarien vor der ukraine vor
den jetzt und lohans die möglicherweise
parallelen aufweisen einzelfälle sind
natürlich immer gegeben aber wenn man
sich anguckt was in abchasien passiert
ist oder in südossetien oder in
transnistrien dann sind das dinge die
zumindest zu den ereignissen heute abend
parallelen aufweisen können
noch eine frage zum schluss axel du bist
jetzt ja für uns in der ukraine in kiew
hast du schon jetzt vielleicht kurz
spüren können oder vielleicht auch den
tag über es schwelte ja schon die ganze
zeit so ein bisschen die sorge dass das
passieren könnte wie geht es den
menschen vor ort jetzt gerade ist die
angst jetzt noch größer geworden dass da
jetzt also auch bis nach kiew in weiten
teilen der ukraine ist also zu
ausschreitungen kommen könnte
also ich habe in den vergangenen tagen
immer wieder berichtet dass die menschen
gerade hier in kiew in der ukrainische
hauptstadt sehr gefasst sind dass man
hier keine menschen in panik über die
straßenrennen sie dass wir gestern abend
auf dem majdan auf dem
geschichtsträchtigen beiden liebespaare
beobachtet haben die sehr ähnlich waren
die einfach im moment gelebt haben also
ich würde nicht von gross ausgeprägter
kriegsangst hier in der ukraine sprechen
zumindest nicht hier in kiew und was man
nicht vergessen darf wenn wir über
kriegsangst reden es gibt ja einen krieg
sei 2014 nämlich im osten des landes die
menschen sind ein stück weit auch
gewöhnt an kriegerische militärische
auseinandersetzung in ihrem land das
heißt aber natürlich nicht dass sie sich
nicht wünschen würden inständig wünschen
würden dass endlich etwas ruhe einkehrt
ob die ereignisse heute abend dazu
beitragen das wage ich jetzt mal zu
bezweifeln ich warne aber auch davor
jetzt davon auszugehen dass jetzt alles
noch größer wird noch stärker eskaliert
das ist sicherlich eine möglichkeit aber
wissen kann man das zur stunde nicht
vielen dank axel sturm für uns live in
kiew in der ukraine
und ja und wir haben jetzt die
möglichkeit das ganze auch noch ein
bisschen einzuordnen vielleicht auch was
das für reaktionen hervorrufen könnte in
der ganzen welt und das wollen wir
machen gemeinsam mit markus kaim von der
stiftung wissenschaft und politik der
mir jetzt zugeschaltet ist schon guten
abend herr kein
vielleicht eine frage zum anfang die
jetzt trotzdem irgendwie interessant
dass und alle beschäftigt was heißt das
jetzt also wenn also die beiden regionen
johansson jetzt von präsident putin
jetzt also anerkannt worden sind als
unabhängige staaten als unabhängige
republiken was bedeutet das genau heißt
das jetzt tatsächlich dass er vielleicht
auch plant noch weiter bis an die
grenzen dieser region jetzt noch weiter
vorzudringen was können wir da jetzt
also erwarten in den nächsten tagen und
wochen
es ist vor allen dingen einen schlag in
das gesicht der europäer ein schlag in
das gesicht der bundesregierung klar
kinder zu geben sich darüber zu sicher
regierung weil er hat ja heute den
metzger format
genommen die format eine absage erteilt
das weihwasser 2015 eckpunkte einer
westlichen ukraine politik gewesen sind
das bemühen zwischen der ukraine und
russland zu vermitteln zu einer
konfliktlösung
aber konflikt einigung zu kommen das hat
er jetzt mit allen fehlern vom tisch
genommen und er hat vor allen dingen die
bemühungen der deutschen
außenministers
französisch der letzten wochen
das abstimmt dass das jetzt seit einiger
zeit beobachten dass europa nicht als
fraktions richtig viele gute gründe dass
es darum geht den usa zu reden und da
ist präsident putin ganz offensichtlich
kein interesse hat an existieren in
conflict regierungsmechanismen und
konfliktregelung format was das jetzt
für den nächsten tage heißt weiß ich
nicht aber es geht das schlimmste zu
befürchten weil
mit heute abend sanktionen in gang
setzen und so schmerzhaft dass ich
glaube hromadka nach draußen sie haben
es angesprochen
es gab also viele gespräche gerade in
den letzten tagen und wochen in seiner
rede dieser einstündigen rede hat sich
putin auch besonders auf die
vergangenheit bezogen also er hat weit
ausgeholt da sprach er zum beispiel
davon 1990 hätte man russland
versprochen bei der wiedervereinigung
deutschlands dass es nicht zur ost
erweiterung kommen würde alles leere
worte hat er das genannt er hat außerdem
davon gesprochen dass russland ja seine
verpflichtung erfüllt hätte armeen
abgezogen hätte und das war fand ich
auch noch interessant er hat von einer
begegnung gesprochen dass nannte er das
würde jetzt zum ersten mal öffentlich
sagen nämlich 2000 als clinton präsident
clinton damals der us-präsident nach
moskau kam hätte er ihn gefragt was
würden die usa von einem nato beitritt
russlands halten und dann sagte putin
die reaktion sehr verhalten gewesen
er hat es ein bisschen also dargestellt
als sei das jetzt alles nur eine
reaktion russlands also auf die aktion
von den usa von der usa und von dem
westen war das jetzt auch teil also
seiner seiner erzählung ist dass das
narrativ was er da jetzt gerade bedienen
möchte oder wie es das einzuschätzen
native ist mir bisher das sagen
das ist ja eine große
politik im netz jahre um zu sagen zehnte
mann seien betrogen worden das ist
versprochen wurden die russische seite
kann bis heute kein einziges dokument
preisen aus dem hervorging dass die nato
osterweiterung
nicht
oder umgekehrt
hallo ich höre sie nachher kein sie
konstanter sprechen ich kann sie gut
verstehen
dass die russische seite kann kein
dokument vorweisen das aus dem
hervorgehen dass die nato ausgeschlossen
worden sei und präsident gorbatschow
sagt ähnliches außenminister james baker
den damaligen verhandlungen
handys der außenpolitische berater von
bundeskanzler gesagt genau das gleiche
also das ist nicht wirklich angst zu
nehmen und tatsächlich wird hier ein
narrativ verdient der einkreisung
russland ist von russland dass der
westen russland böses wollen und das ist
eigentlich in deckung zu bringen mit der
wertschätzung westlicher politik
russland im 90er und 2000er jahre wir
haben die nato russland und ab 1997
russland als strategischer partner
beschrieben wird der nato-russland-rat
seit 2002 russland eine besondere rolle
für die nato instituts
also man kann nicht einfach behaupten
oder ist einfach nicht zutreffend zu
behaupten dass die nato russland
vermeintliche
tätliche entdeckungen zu bringen jetzt
gerade am ende hat mir in kurzen
aussetzer aber davor habe ich sie sehr
gut verstanden was natürlich jetzt auch
alle besonders interessiert also wenn es
jetzt dazu kommt
johansson jetzt werden als unabhängig
anerkannt dann ist natürlich auch ein
dieser schritt ermöglicht es der
russischen truppen also in diesen
gebieten diesen gebieten stationiert zu
werden und dann ist natürlich auch die
nächste frage wie würde es da
weitergehen was ist zwar zu befürchten
und da haben wir ein stück vorbereitet
von luton leinhos da schauen wir kurz
zusammen rein
mehr als 150.000 soldaten hat russland
nahe der ukrainischen grenze
zusammengezogen die einmarsch szenarien
westlicher geheimdienste ein vorstoß aus
richtung norden teils auch über belarus
eine invasion in die ost ukraine ein
angriff im süden von der bereits
annektierten krim so gut wie immer
spielt dabei der rapper fluss eine
wesentliche rolle der gewaltige stromes
so etwas wie eine natürliche
verteidigungslinie
ukrainische militär strategen glauben
dass der einmarsch in der ost ukraine
beginnt dort kämpft die armee seit
jahren gegen russische separatisten
die abtrünnigen gebiete in lugansk und
don jetzt wären dabei wichtiges
aufmarschgebiet zusätzlich könnten
truppen nördlich und südlich davon
richtung tampa fluss vorrücken
auch von der krim und vom schwarzen meer
aus könnte der angriff erfolgen moskau
hat truppen und kriegsschiffe hierher
verlegt
erstes ziel wäre wohl die landenge von
peri kopp die einzige verbindung zum
festland von dort könnte russland die
ukraine komplett vom schwarzen meer
abschneiden
einig sind sich die meisten experten wie
ein angriff ablaufen könnte erst
cyberattacken auf militärische
kommandostruktur
mobilfunknetze und stromversorgung dann
luft und raketenangriffe ukrainische
luftwaffe und flugabwehr zu schwächen
anschließend rücken bodentruppen 1
eine große unbekannte ist das wetter
noch ist es kalt der boden gefroren doch
wird es wärmer als in sumpfigen gelände
kommen panzer und fahrzeuge nur noch
schwer voran
weil es mögliche szenarien herkam jetzt
sind sie leider nicht mehr da dabei
wollten wir doch jetzt noch über zwei
fragen sprechen sie sind wieder bei uns
wunderbar denn in der community gibt es
viele fragen deshalb zum schluss
natürlich noch mal die ganz dringende
frage von callas bei youtube die wird
der westen die nato die usa jetzt
reagieren was glauben sie
die europäische union hat bereits gesagt
die erkennung der beiden volksrepublik
oder anderen auch als volksrepublik in
russischer sicht
und massive konsequenzen haben ein
europäisches sanktionspaket wird dann
auch den weg gebracht heute abend und
damit werden die handlungsspielraum für
die diplomatie enger man kann nicht
gleichzeitig sanktionen bringen und in
die hand ausgestreckt halten das wird so
nicht akzeptieren entscheidend wird sein
was in den nächsten tagen passieren also
sehr vieles vorstellbar aber das ist
weiß angetan worden eine hilfe der
beiden regierungen anführungsstrichen
diesen jetzt anerkannt neun staaten und
eine russische militärpräsenz wenig wie
die folge
nicht auszuschließen ist eine voll
ausgebildete aktion wie die creme also
die integration dieser beiden
volksrepublik in die nach ostern hinein
und dann bleibt zu schlechter letzt eben
auch die option eines ausgebildeten
militärischen eingriffen wie er selber
also an den versionen das ist heute
abend schnell zu sehen und dann
vielleicht zum ende doch noch eine frage
und zwar big ed bei youtube fragt sich
sind die separatisten gebiete nicht teil
der ukraine warum kann jetzt putin
darüber bestimmen was mit dem
hoheitsgebiet eines souveränen
souveränen staates so passiert
absolut die beobachtung ist nämlich
richtig es handelt sich in circles trägt
ihre träger und es gibt kein staat zum
nächstbesten diesem schritt folgen girls
der enge der anerkennung genauso wie die
bundesregierung die annexion der krim
ich anerkannt sie betraten sie nach wie
vor zwei dinge würde das wieder der fall
sein aber seit 2014 befinden sie sich
die region art schwebezustand
die ukrainische regierung behauptet mit
russischer unterstützung hätten die
separatisten dort breit gemacht
selbst einige autonome regierung
entwickelt und russland würde diese
beiden region nutzen um druck aus dem
ukrainisch die junge auszügen großer
sich die seine wirklich andere lautet
sein dass sich um einen internen
konflikt es handelt sich um einen
aufstand einer russischsprachigen
minderheit die von der ukrainische
regierung unterdrückt wurde mit allem
recht auf selbstbestimmung und autonomie
und sie verdiene die unterstützung der
russischen seite und die zweite leseart
setzt sich jetzt deutlich mit ungewissem
ausgang
vielen dank für diese einschätzung an
markus kaim von der stiftung
wissenschaft und politik vielen dank für
heute abend
und ihr seid natürlich jederzeit weiter
bei uns informiert zum beispiel in einer
halben stunde im heute journal da wird
das natürlich auch noch einmal thema bei
uns sein und ansonsten natürlich auch
jederzeit bei uns online bei zdf heute
vielen dank dass ihr dabei war für
dieses live und eure aufmerksamkeit bis
dahin tschüss